three-two-one huge thanks to YouTube
Reds new series Cobra Kai for sponsoring
today's video as you might know it's the
continuation of the Karate Kid universe
and today one of the stars of the show
Tanner Buchanan is here to help us with
a very special challenge
say hi tanner what's going on now
today's challenge we will be trying to
catch foam darts using nothing but
chopsticks obviously this idea is
inspired by the original Karate Kid film
or mr. Miyagi is trying to catch a fly
and Danny Larusso comes in and he's like
let me try he catches it mr. Miyagi runs
out saying beginner's luck well
hopefully we'll have a little bit of
beginner's luck today because I think
this is gonna be pretty difficult when I
moved to LA I was really bad with
chopsticks you're eating sushi in Little
Tokyo for eight years nine years I'm not
good with chopsticks as well Noah here
Noah is our martial arts expert and he's
going to be helping us channel our inner
strength
how are your reflexes Tanner I think
very well yeah yeah kela catch a
mosquito in your bare hands like I kept
my why sometimes yeah okay that's
promising ready three two one
[Music]
try to get ready that was close time to
pick up all the darts all right who's
next you got it buddy I don't know I
went okay cuz it was coming over my
right shoulder it's not coming this way
it might bring me back but coming in I
think it's all about the stance like
when he's doing he has a traditional
Muay Thai stances he's got his lead leg
in front I like yeah there we go
camera angles and camera angles that's
how you do it there we go yeah we're
training like that he's definitely gonna
get it watch yeah all right it's about
grace not power great - what
[Music]
Hardman is fast watch let me go let me
go let me show you guys watch I don't I
don't get it at all all right and three
two one that was a good one problem is
I'm thinking too much and this feel
horse drops of stance throw a couple to
me let's see if this helps
okay this is this is in pot it's gonna
be impossible
I always thought at least with the
SmartArt she pulled it with two fingers
on the tip and you kind of just put your
finger lightly on the back to guide it
but I'm finding that it's easier
actually to push with the finger in the
back on these bigger darts in those
bigger darts and this bigger duck
Oh chopsticks you know what I think I
think all of us need to gather around
for the chopsticks and one person throws
it we all try to catch it at the same
time dude guess who just showed up we
got a wild salmon appearing it's it's
not like you go to bed and wake up I get
a certain time it's more like it's sleep
windows I'm gonna try and sleep between
10 and 10 as much as I can and then you
just know that for about three hours in
that period you're not gonna be sleeping
but you're not pulling in control in
those hours are I'd say the whole thing
is actually a lot easier it's it's it's
like strenuous and tense at times but
like it's very simple that's the thing
his baby is there simple beings
sometimes they get poop on there but
other than that they're a piece of cake
through there they're the least picky
people there's funny I had a conference
health Jake and Nico the other day that
was just to check in and holding the
baby is we're talking and we're like
just talking and the baby's just like
dude like straight into like the
microphone like sorry guys like I
couldn't you'd it couldn't you did it
I just wanted to come by though today
and see what's happening because seeing
all these cool things on the internet
that you guys are doing I'm feeling like
I'm getting FOMO like you're missing out
a bit
yeah yeah well actually it's like a
mancation right now though that's what
paternity leagues like yeah actually I
do have a baby video ideas which is
Hawaiian heroes as well because I'm
gonna grab the camera and film insert
shots for the beast this is a baby in
the script and I got a baby now and I
want to make sure there's a some
authentic close-up baby shots that are
free once the I'm running bet with Sara
right now to see what the hospital bills
gonna be I mean obviously we have
insurance but we were like was thrown on
big numbers do you realize you guys went
to the hospital that Jenna works at yeah
yeah I do realize that but thankfully we
I didn't have to see her for any reason
yeah if he'd seen her that would have
been bad news yes oh hey I got an
Instagram account you should follow have
you have you seen this this this page
cinematography DV he had this is all in
the cinema 4d but what the purpose of
this is is that it's trying to deal with
like real world lighting recreations in
with the same scene no so funny
carmichael was literally just showing me
this account like two days ago he
started learning cinema 4d because of
this that's crazy
ya know this popped up on my recommended
like okay dang yeah you're not I mean
yeah that's super interesting yeah the
exact same shot but different lighting
setup and it like completely feels
differently it's like one is a spy movie
one's like an alien invasion movie one's
a super you know you're like whoa it's
like it's crazy seeing how that stuff
really functions like that might be shot
I think it was a good call to put
treason
kinds of trees I'm just like man trees
are great I got plenty more trees okay
wow that looks it looks pretty good you
can tell at least what the beginning
shots is that progressively more and
more trees get put in the scene being
able to see like the trees and like the
side of the road getting illuminated and
home
well that was why I put the trees in in
the first place is because I wanted
something to catch the headlights light
bet and then it looks so good they're so
easy to implement and didn't impact
render times that much I just kept
putting on them yeah they're like that
that shot has that weird drift but with
a little bit of Rumble it'll be fine
sweet it's so shiny and glistening I
love it there's a right here so we can
do slow motion right now we're rolling
at 150 frames a second another cool
thing the REC can do is pre record so
it's running a 10-second buffer all the
time and then you just if you see
something cool just ten seconds you hit
record and it saves that clip that's how
they get the footage of sharks jumping
out of the water
unlike the Discovery Channel is they're
sitting there and the cameras always
rolling but it's only sitting like the
last 30 seconds or the last 10 seconds
and then once the shark finally jumps
out of the water they save the last 10
seconds and the first time the Gotham is
a big historical event because film
cameras can't do pre record and digital
cameras weren't able to get that
slow-motion up until that point I think
if red throws and we go with training
darts I think our chances are gonna go
up so there's no way those nuts are
gonna get through now we have a
strategic line of defense with training
darts all the way to sensei noah who has
twin dragon twin dragons Kimpo chuff's
there's no way there's no way a darts
gonna get through here hey you guys
ready ready I don't think anyone's gonna
get it I don't think anyone's even gonna
come remotely grello stock more throw he
just talked told me to talk
looks like they want you to die today
that's alright my cash my cash interview
yes it's my fault
how's it great
[Music]
oh that was close diamond this is a
really tiny strike zone give me a break
hang out wait for the wind
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't believe none of us thought we'd
actually get this how does it feel I
feel I feel like I should just retire
from life at this point sorry you came
all the way out just to watch me yeah
that's fine I feel accomplished it was a
team effort we all did it we all did it
well that's it remember Cobra Kai
premieres May 2nd on YouTube read the
first two episodes are free so go on
their support Tanner and if you liked it
give YouTube reddit right
[Music]